block chain und crypto währungen wie
bitcoin waren nur der anfang dann kam
eine idee die das internet und unsere
art zu arbeiten für immer verändern
könnte es ist die geschichte eines
familienvaters aus sachsen mit einer
vision sie lautet darum
dezentralisierte autonome organisation
was das ist
dafür fahren wir einmal an mit dir stell
dir mal vor das bist du und das ist dein
chef der sagt dir was du zu tun hast
und über deinem chef hat dein chef
natürlich auch einen chef und die ist
schärfen für ganz viele andere chefs
gleichzeitig die wiederum chefs von ganz
vielen leuten so wie du sind so kennen
wir dieses system jedes unternehmen jede
politische partei sogar jeder
fußballverein ist so aufgebaut aber das
heißt auch wenn jemand einen chef hat
der nicht ganz perfekt ist dann leiden
alle darunter wenn jemand seine
verantwortung nicht ernst nimmt wenn
jemand unfreundlich ist wenn jemand aus
den falschen gründen befördert wird dann
funktioniert das alles nicht mehr
wirklich also können wir das ganze nicht
mal anders denken eine organisation ohne
hierarchien ohne chefs bestehend nur aus
menschen und aus kot
möglich gemacht durch die blogs
und dieses konzept hat einen namen
[Musik]
dezentrale autonome organisation
ich glaube in fünf oder zehn jahren wird
es komplett normal sein für eine dauer
zu arbeiten oder mit einer dauer
eine ziemlich berühmte da wo auch wenn
es etwas albern klingt heißt die nada da
wollten ein paar leute einfach ein
abendessen veranstalten einfach nur als
kleines experiment aber das wurde zu
einem kulturellen phänomen weil
plötzlich jede menge leute beitreten
wollten
überall im internet experimentieren
heute crypto fenster mit macht in das
neu zu verteilen es gibt eine klima da
die co2 zertifikate kaufen will eine
frau die ein fast food restaurant
eröffnen möchte eine ukraine dar mit der
die gründerin der band pussycat geld für
die ukraine gesammelt hat und das alles
ist vielleicht nur der anfang aber um
daraus wirklich zu verstehen müssen wir
weiter zurückgehen zu der person die die
erste richtige da ins leben gerufen hat
mein name ist christoph münch ich komm
heraus mit weiter ich bin ein
familienmensch sie hat sieben kinder ich
bin entwickler die idee ist und es
damals gewesen 2016 um 15 uhr angefangen
haben jeder konnte geld in form von er
einstecken man kommt raus einen toten
sowie anteile an dieser organisation
nicht mitbekommen okay vielleicht müssen
wir noch weiter zurückgehen ja das war
während meiner doktoranden seit ungefähr
sommer 2013 denn vor fast zehn jahren
macht christoph jens eine entdeckung im
internet und auch wenn er es da noch
nicht weiß wird diese entdeckung sein
leben verändern ein paar phone
einträglich in einem blogpost dazu und
eben das whitepaper von unserer vision
ag motto natur china kam motor ist eines
der größten rätsel des internets wer
hinter diesem namen steckt ist ein
geheimnis wer auch immer es ist
veröffentlicht ende 2008 ein whitepaper
einen leitfaden für eine dezentrale
währung die ohne staat und ohne banken
funktioniert er nennt sie bitte
ich habe mich schon im studium sehr als
für selbst organisierte das thema
basierender systeme interessiert so
alles was man oft natur auf findet wo es
keine klaren führung gibt aber ameisen
und viele andere hatte auf ja die
organisieren sich selbst und das habe
ich immer fasziniert köln war für mich
genauso ein system mit keulen
funktioniert durch eine technologie
namens blog chain einem blog chain ist
eine datenbank die alles mögliche
dokumentieren kann im fall von bitcoin
dokumentiert sie wer wieviel bitcoin
besitzt und wer wem seine bitcoin weiter
schickt anders als eine normale
datenbank wird eine block 10 aber nicht
nur auf einem einzelnen rechner
abgespeichert sondern auf tausenden
rechnern gleichzeitig jeder speichert
eine komplette kopie der datenbank die
sich permanent aktualisiert das heißt
wenn jemand versucht die datenbank zu
fälschen sich selber mehr bitcoin
zuzuschieben als er eigentlich hat dann
können alle anderen rechner einspringen
und ihm überstimmen die aufzeichnungen
der block chain lassen sich also nicht
fälschen es sei denn mehr als die hälfte
der weltweiten bitcoin rechenleistung
fälscht gleichzeitig auf die gleiche
weise
und das ist die technologie die die welt
verändern denn nach bitcoin folgt die
nächste idee bitcoin ist einem blog
chain mit der man virtuelles geld hin
und herschieben kann nicht mehr nicht
weniger aber könnte man auf der blog
noch viel mehr tun verträge abschließen
unternehmen gründen kunst verkaufen
alles ohne dass man jemanden in der
mitte braucht der das ganze autorisiert
das ist die idee von vitali gute riemen
und nancy ist serie dann kam das junge
paar aus von metallic ich weiß nicht
wann ist genau gelesen hab es kann sein
soll es war wahrscheinlich der so januar
februar um irgendwo irgendwas worum
ausland gestoßen so ähnlich wie eine
urkunde entsteht indem ich ein stück
papier nehme das unterschreibe und ein
notar siegel drauf kommt so ähnlich wird
über diese technologie eine
elektronische datei wieder vor beliebig
oft vervielfältigt war zu einer
eindeutigkeit und durch diese
eindeutigkeit der datei so ähnlich wie
der urkunde trägt sie genauso im grunde
auch für die urkunde dann einen eigenen
wert von dem ist klar gehört er mir oder
gehört einem dritten und was ist er
genau und es war davor nicht digital
lösbar und die möglichkeiten die das war
innerhalb wollen wir eigentlich wäre
alles sofort klar aber ich habe nur
ahnen können was damit möglich war und
seitdem gab es für mich eigentlich
technisch gesehen kommt etwas anderes
aber juli um hat seine kritiker die
block chain ist zum beispiel noch recht
langsam viel langsamer als ein
herkömmlicher computer ihre werkzeuge
werden immer wieder von betrügern
genutzt und aktuell verbraucht sie noch
jede menge strom aber trotzdem die
menschen die an i4i um glauben diesen
eines abends waren wir zu besuch bei den
ferien entwicklern in berlin ich weiß
noch genau da waren diese idealistischen
hacker die haben diese fantastische
technologie gebaut
und ich habe mir gedacht diese leute
verstehen nicht wirklich wie die welt
funktioniert aber
[Musik]
trotzdem musste ich sie werden die welt
verändert und
in dieser zeit arbeitet christoph münch
an genau so eine idee die die welt
verändern könnte da steht für dezentrale
autonome organisation die idee ist und
ist damals gewesen 2016 um 15 uhr
angefangen haben jeder konnte geld in
form von er einstecken man kommt raus
einen toten sowas wie anteile an dieser
organisation und warum wollte er so
etwas bauen
warum alles können und das war auch
schon manchmal der ganze grund navi hat
gar kein geld verdient also ist man
gleich aussehen auch ein großes
missverständnis auf da ist wir haben
nicht einen euro jemals dafür bekommen
und so soll die dauer funktionieren wenn
du in die da hinein willst kannst du
dich einkaufen und zwar mit äther das
ist die krypto währung der i4i um block
chain die krypto währung landet dann im
großen tresorraum der dauer und jetzt
kannst du dich mit anderen austauschen
und ihr könnt gemeinsam entscheiden was
mit dem geld im tresorraum passieren
soll
vielleicht wollt ihr in eine
geschäftsidee investieren oder das geld
an eine gute sache spenden oder
vielleicht wollt ihr es für marketing
ausgeben damit noch mehr leute von der
dauer erfahren und noch mehr geld da ist
alles ist möglich und die dauer
mitglieder können alle zusammen
abstimmen
am 30 april 2016 geht die dauer auf der
ferien blog chain in betrieb noch hat
niemand eine ahnung wie viele leute ihr
beitreten werden oder wie viel geld sie
einsammeln wird
wir hatten das leck gehabt mit 5.000
nutzern wenn alle davon die da drin sind
1000 euro käme das ist ungefähr fünf
millionen aber es kommt anders man kann
er alles hätte nicht planen die gibt's
einfach manchmal irgendwas geht einfach
viral und die dauer ist einfach wir
reingegangen und alle anderen gesprochen
allem darüber geschrieben waren auf der
titelseite von new york times gewesen
sonntagsausgabe es war einfach völlig
bewältigt die aufmerksamkeit generiert
hat was so in rom das ist letztendlich
ein etwa 150 millionen dollar
eingenommen wurden was natürlich niemand
aber das hat wirklich niemand innerhalb
eines monats wird die dauer von einer
obskuren idee zur größten kraut von den
kampagne aller zeiten
150 millionen dollar bedeutet jeder
siebte keulen der krypto währung meter
liegt in der
dazu zu sehen die videoqualität tagen
mehrere millionen quasi außen immer
größere oder immer größer gute das hat
uns schnellstens ein gewusst was ist
denn diese da ist schlechte sache
finanziert dinge für die ich persönlich
nicht stehe die moralisch verwerflich
sind oder andere dinge und ich bin damit
meinem namen irgendwo damit verbunden
und will eigentlich gar nichts mehr
damit zu tun haben das zweite ist die
daumen für immer leben filme existieren
niemand kann sie jemals stoppen so hatte
ich angst dass ich mir irgendwann mal
gehen würde dass ich dazu beigetragen
habe einen monster zu schaffen worüber
ich keine kontrolle mehr habe und
christoph angst ist nicht unbegründet
die daraus die das vorbild für hunderte
dezentrale organisation war ist nämlich
vor allem bekannt für eine sache sie
wurde gehackt die das projekt an dem
christoph und sein team monatelang
gearbeitet haben wird in nur einem
moment auf den kopf gestellt
150 millionen dollar stehen auf dem
spiel ein cyberkrieg und um einen hacker
und ein team das die verlorenen crypto
millionen sagt wir erzählen euch in der
zdf mediathek
es ist die geschichte eines traums und
eine geschichte vom scheitern
sie hat das internet für immer verändert
in der neuen folge von digital empire
der krippe visionär und der millionen
drauf klickt einfach hier
[Musik]